juli
[Musik]
unser job ist ja oft einfach verfolgung
beobachtung und auflauern
also manchmal frage ich mich echt wo
hört die heute show auf und wo fängt
stalking an und machen da einige von uns
nicht ihr hobby zum beruf
das ist das war einer solchen die das
böse das stimmt auf keinen fall
also ich sehe uns da er so als groupies
die so einen geilen musiker hinterher
reisen und geiler musiker das heißt in
unserem fall dann halt leider manchmal
spd kanzlerkandidat in einem sind sich
alle einig es muss endlich schluss sein
mit der großen koalition
wir nehmen deshalb alles strapazen auf
uns und reisen martin schulz einen tag
lang durchs ganze bundesgebiet hinterher
ich sammle unterschriften dass die spd
wieder in die opposition geht um die spd
zu retten
ich bin aber bundeskanzler wäre das hört
man ihre position noch natürlich später
irgendwann wir müssen die spd retten
haben sie darauf pocht darauf dass die
spd mal irgendwann so wieder was sowieso
ein profil bekommt ja durchaus aber hat
sie ja eigentlich jetzt wieder mit
martin schulz soziale gerechtigkeit so
war es eigentlich eine person macht
leider noch kein profil das ist richtig
aber gut ich werde es gibt ja viele
junge leute in der spd so wie ich mein
junge leute machen auch noch kein profil
aber die
wir bemühen uns redlich wieder ein zu
bekommen wie wäre es mit inhalten
inhalten sind gut ja herr schulz ich bin
ja auf ihrer seite ich möchte die spd
auch retten er tatsächlich aber ich
glaube nur dass das mit einer gruppe
nicht möglich ist wie wäre es denn
folgendermaßen sie wollen herr
bundeskanzler werden
wie wäre es so sie werden
oppositionsführer aber wir sagen ihnen
alle sie sind bundeskanzler das gute
idee wir machen so wir müssen uns
beeilen martin schulz einholen das wird
diese wahl wohl das einzige kopf an kopf
rennen auf geht's
[Musik]
rocco macht neun von zehn menschen doof
ist es so gehen bis zu
nein die macht nicht gerufen denn das
kann man doch nicht alle neun von zehn
gruppe verursacht erektilen dysfunktion
auch bei frauen
damit habe ich nichts zu tun ich greife
zu anderen mitteln
sie werden ganz müde die großen börse
sie gehen nicht in die koalition mit der
cdu
sie gehen in die opposition bei mir ist
das immer so wenn ich den welt gesehen
da war ich auf wenn ich sie da schlafe
ich ja wenn sie wenn sie so schlagfertig
sind warum waren sie das nicht im tv
duell macht es auch egal
hinterher
[Applaus]
[Musik]
der großen koalition geht die spd ja
leider immer kaputt so ein bisschen wie
in der ehe da gibt es immer den einen
partner der so ein bisschen der chef ist
und der andere wer sich also die jahre
durchschlägt den tv heiratet sind sie
verheiratet ja okay und geben überlegt
dass ich da bin ich wieder ich wollte
noch mal ein autogramm wenigstens haben
ein letztes autogramm jetzt schon mal
der stift und hier das schild von
deutschem boden soll nie wieder eine
gruppe aus gehen
ja unterschreiben wollte zwar nicht aber
dafür hat man meinen kopf berührt ich
werde nicht nur wieder waschen
er wird doch kanzler ich glaube jetzt
wieder zurück ins studio
[Applaus]
[Musik]
ich war damals so in der story drin ich
habe echt mehrere wochen geglaubt ich
würde in würselen wohnen ja da gibt es
nur eine vorstellung die noch absurder
ist du wohnst in würselen es klingelt an
der tür und draußen stehen die grünen in
deutschland geht die angst um die grünen
machen häuser wahlkampf oder auch bei
ihnen kann es jeden moment an der tür
klingelt aber bevor ich die beiden
grünen haustür wahlkämpfer treffe will
ich erst mal wissen was die menschen von
der aktion halten die grünen machen
gerade häuser wahlkampf und ziehen von
tür zu tür öffnen sie das gut nein nein
würden sie keinen grünen reinlassen nein
ich las sowieso kein rein den ich nicht
kenne zum beispiel katrin göring eckardt
kennen sie ja ist mir ganz egal wer das
ist aber ich will keine tür haben ich
informiere mich anderweitig kleine
warnung die grünen sind in der stadt da
sag ich mal grün ist leben und wo das
leben ist bin ich auch ich sage immer
lieber ein haus im grünen als ein grünen
im haus dagegen sage ich grün lässt sich
nicht verderben es seite man vergiftet
das grün
da ist das grillen leider tot sind sie
poet oder haben sie irgendwie die hand
genommen
ich konnte und wenn die anrufen richtig
auf
also für mich nicht super mal sehen wie
es mit den beiden kandidaten wird okay
leute ich würde sagen wir proben jetzt
erstmal den schlachtruf was ist grün und
klingelt an türen michael kellner
michaela müssen jetzt schon alle mit
zweimal klingelt welche wenn der kellner
zweimal klingelt dann wird das was wir
ein wahlergebnis die witze macht hier
schon immer noch ich
[Musik]
erste situation hier wird jetzt
geklingelt hallo hier ist michael keller
von den grünen ich würde gern
informationen zur landtagswahl
verwaltungen
doch michael keller von den grünen
vorbei kommt information zur
landtagswahl
dann machte auch noch aus wer auch immer
auf gemacht hat als die bürger sehen wer
da kommt bleibt die wohnungstür zu
[Musik]
erstes haus haben wir acht mal
geklingelt keiner hat aufgemacht wie ist
die erste zwischenbilanz
das café ich mal gucken wie es weiter
geht ja wir haben jetzt gerade nochmal
flyer in den briefkästen oder lassen nur
da wo keine werbung drauf stand oder
ziehen wir weiter im nächsten haus kommt
man immerhin schon mal ins gespräch
[Musik]
haben sie interesse am thermomix wir
sind von stern tv gesehen habe auch alle
häuser gleich aus irgendwie kann es sein
dass wir immer die gleiche auslaufen
wie ist das jetzt nach dem gespräch
werden sie jetzt die grünen nicht wählen
oder auf gar keinen fall wählen
das muss man sich noch mal überlegen
also viel hat das nicht geändert ob ja
oder nein das können die beiden noch tun
hatte sie daher natürlich aus welcher
etwas ich meinen der herr nur einer von
beiden oder vielleicht ihm dann dass sie
dann einfach nicht mehr mit wochen im
haus nummer 4 macht eine b g einen
entscheidenden fehler und lässt die
grünen in die wohnung
dann redet kandidat andresen sehr sehr
lange lange
[Musik]
haben die beiden euch überzeugt wird ihr
sagen ja dass noch ein gute argumente
die wählen wir dass ich noch mal drüber
schlafen aber prinzipiell gehe ich mit
einem positiven gefühl aus dem gespräch
auf jeden fall raus aber das reicht doch
nicht leute wir sind doch eh seit
ewigkeiten hier die wissen noch nichtmal
die grünen wählen wie viel zeit weil wir
den dennoch verbringen
ich habe ja nicht mal wir bekommen wir
machen das damit leuten ins gespräch zu
kommen nicht damit losfahren nach außen
ihr bekommt ja das sehe ich anders
kinder damit ich hier auch noch was
mitnehmen von den tag danke und dann
kann der bundesgeschäftsführer den
beiden doch noch helfen indem er ein fan
foto macht und zwar mit mir
ich habe langsam das gefühl ich muss den
beiden grünen mal unter die arme greifen
wenn sie nicht aufmachen erhöhen wir
ihnen die steuern führen abend die
beiden herren verfolgen mich schon den
ganzen abend können sie wird die polizei
ruft ein mäßig erfolgreicher abend neigt
sich dem ende zu ich würde sagen zum
abschied erproben wir nochmal den
schlachtruf mal gucken aber jetzt sitzt
was ist grün und klingelt an türen nicht
sicher wer wird diese wahl verlieren
martin scholz und angela merkel
[Musik]
ich zog er immer noch zusammen wenn es
an der tür klingelt ja nicht verstehen
trotzdem schön dass wir so viel
rumkommen ich meine in unserem job da
kommst du an orte mit fremder sprache
komischer kultur und unverständlichen
sitten
du warst einmal in bayern einmal das hat
mich für immer verändert die fdp
plakatierte er mit politik mit neuwagen
gebrochen haben sie nicht angst laut den
umfragen dass er politik mit
totalschaden wird das ist ja macht was
sich hier ausleben
durch das mikrofon und 100 gut zu üben
macht aus sie entscheiden wann sie es
mit entziehen wenn sie selber sprechen
und das finden so warum darf ich das
mikro nicht mal halten
naja weil sich kein reporter sind
sondern die politiker wir können gern
die rollen tauschen wenn ich die rede
halten darf das würde ich gerne sehen
dann machen wir das doch gleich super
und mich darauf es ist sofort sofort
richtig gern dass nicht nur noch einmal
ich freue mich sehr hier zu sein in
ingolstadt und dann auch noch bei der
fdp
ja das war doch schon der erste gang
hier ist die stimme mir werdet ihr die
anderen parteien platt machen
christina nein gerufen wir wollen dort
sorgen das land gestalten aber für uns
ist demokratie nicht darauf ausgerichtet
den politischen wettbewerber zu
vernichten wollen sie die leute
überzeugen dass ihr das land gestalten
wollen und die politik nicht darauf
ausgerichtet ist den wettbewerber zu
vernichten
[Applaus]
was erwarten sie sich von der
veranstaltung heute hier guten kaffee in
nette leute fröhliche atmosphäre das
wetter stabil bleibt kein regen und
danach noch ein prozent mehr
ja sehr gut sie haben es wirklich drauf
mit dem nicht inhaltlich werden ist ja
so etwas zum programm auch bundesweit
machen nein jetzt reden wir über
betäubungslose ferkelkastration dann
werde ich sehr endlich wollen sie
darüber was hören wir hier irgendjemand
über kastration reden ja ich war nachher
noch zur csu
solch markus oder was ausrichten ja mein
beileid erklärt transportieren was
nämlich hängen aber da klafft hier
sollten sie dennoch die nummer von den
grünen-spitzenkandidaten hier geben
damit sich markus söder vielleicht eine
videobotschaft an die aufnehmen lassen
kann
markus söder eine videowirtschaft ja
kann ich machen von hartmann und schulze
wurde exakt nichts worüber ich bin in
den letzten wochen wenig dazugekommen
nachrichten zu gucken wollte einmal
fragen wie läuft denn der wahlkampf
super in bayern läuft es super in berlin
schwieriger
also berlin ist schuld oder mainz also
beides ist denkbar da war ja ein hammer
witz merkte sie zurecht
ministerpräsident meine quoten sind
besser ist die der heute show ich war
heute schon richtig im wahlkampf
unterwegs ich war bei herrn habeck zum
beispiel und er hat mir seine
telefonnummer gegeben dass wir ihm
vielleicht mal eine videobotschaft
aufzeichnen für die vielleicht
anstehenden koalitionsverhandlungen sind
sie dabei
das war eine andere zeit
das gras war grün der himmelblaue und
der satz söder wird mal kanzler ein witz
heute unvorstellbar deshalb sind ja auch
traditionen so wichtig und auf 1 konnte
man sich in den letzten jahren immer
verlassen
die unendliche geschichte das black city
hat er doch sogar ganz neue
geschäftsfelder ermöglicht man könnte
sagen du hast schon mit klopapier auf
dem schwarzmarkt gehandelt bevor es cool
war
[Musik]
also ich verstehe die ganze aufregung
nicht der praxis der bietet doch eine
menge wirtschaftliche chancen halt nur
nicht für die briten und diese chancen
die werde ich jetzt nutzen
volle kraft voraus
hallo doing some business after the jump
the very expensive everywhere in britain
herz haben hier lustig bananas for
example bekam very expensive zuhälter
jugend zufrieden
das ist kein experte ist kein darf wie
er keiner vegetarian sausage expensive
in britain after the break
[Musik]
[Applaus]
das ist doch sehr kritisch die
das ist milchaufschäumer
[Musik]
ok
seit juni
[Musik]
wie
[Applaus]
bist du irgendwie froh what can be used
to make you stay so yuanta briten zu
liebte you at the end of oktober ist der
emittent city to city exit
[Musik]
lustig
also wenn du mich so nerven würde ist
würde ich auch aus der eu austreten wo
er hattest du eigentlich so viel wie der
chip hat gesagt er unterliegt der
ärztlichen schweigepflicht was na ja wo
wir grad bei allen dingen sind ich muss
nochmal auf markus söder zu bekommen
gerne ich wusste ja schon vor allen
anderen dass unser markus kanzler
potenzial hat jetzt mal viagra hin oder
her aber du hast da auch irgendwelche
pillen geschmissen
kein kommentar
heute ist kein normaler tag denn heute
treffe ich mein idol
markus söder denn der tod gerade durch
bayerische kinos mit seinem
erfolgsprogramm oder persönlich wir
haben sie ein plakat hier hängen gehabt
ja und da haben wir die leute gefragt
wann läuft es eigentlich der film im
süden kommt dahin man kann die
eigentliche und die chance habe ich ihm
erzählt dass er praktisch als filmheld
angesehen worden
deshalb soll ja auch wenn man mal
ehrlich ist oder schaut gut aus kann ich
sagen
[Musik]
das ist einfach eine top typ einfach
muss man ja ist ein top sie ihren mann
für markus söder verlassen
theoretisch wenn ihm nicht gehen würde
ein mann der tat in bayern eine große
persönlichkeit
nach horst seehofer nach horst seehofer
das wird doch nicht gerne hören
deswegen hat seehofer jetzt in berlin
und macht das bestimmt seinen job nicht
schlecht clever gemacht er markus oder
nicht zu unterschätzen ja einen kleinen
wettbewerb wer markus söder von uns
geiler findet also ich finde ich geil
und sie ja doch sie sich steigern
supergeil
[Gelächter]
es sind erotisch aufgeladen haben sie
spaß dass günter gleich sind so
aufgeregt dass sie wieder
[Applaus]
[Musik]
unterschreiben sind wir ein bisschen was
ich bin ihr größter fan
ja aber nicht das mikro wegnehmen das
waren 7 aus und ist nur unterschreiben
ich bin ihr größter fan das heißt nicht
will so werden sie wie sie mit anderen
worten ich will meinen chef brutal
wegbomben dazu müssen sie nur sehr
erwachsen junger mann und eines tages
wird das eben auch noch intendant
jetzt haben sie mich so gut wie seehofer
aber immerhin habe ich die eier meinen
chef jetzt schon weg zu morgen und nicht
zu warten bis er alt und gebrechlich ist
[Applaus]
[Musik]
ich bin extra ganz leise das ist einfach
toll
das ist wirklich ein ganz großer ich
habe noch nie so viele gehaltvolle worte
gehört das ist erst einmal eine frau zu
hause war
da kam die begegnung mit meiner ersten
hund also nicht so weil ich stand am
garten ton klingt dann haben wir später
drüber gehabt jetzt haben ein motto und
so einem zweig bücher und bilder an
fanny und also hunde sind einfach super
es war wirklich haben wir das gar nicht
so toll volk gestellt wird es wirklich
warten war richtig und gerade im kino in
dieser atmosphäre also mehr kann man
nicht verlangen
man geht ja eigentlich ins kino um zu
knutschen ja aber bisschen schade wenn
der schwarm hat vorne auf der bühne so
genau so da ich bin wirklich größter fan
sie mir noch was unterschreiben sie mal
hier was ich haben es angezogen
können sie das nicht unterschreiben nein
hab extra nein danke ich nur ein
autogramm dass ich mir zu hause
aufhängen kann ich habe sogar noch so
ein schild mit anstand sind andere
gucken sie mal ist das nicht schön wenn
wir uns nicht so wenn es die ganze
fraktion trägt beim schon
natürlich ist jetzt aber auch ja eine
unterschrift tut ihnen deutlich weh oder
nein da war ich extra beim söder im kino
und habe nicht mal ein autogramm
gekriegt geh ich halt nach hause kommt
mir den richtigen action film bibi und
tina zurückgeschrieben
[Applaus]
irgendwann da kriege ich diese
unterschrift ja du bist ja noch jung du
kannst dir ruhig ehrgeizige ziele setzen
ich dachte zwar ein studium oder eine
ausbildung aber okay dann halt die
unterschrift von markus söder
nichts ist unmöglich meine an die steuer
könnte verkehrsminister werden ja aber
es ist nicht die ganze zeit über beiden
splitterparteien reden reden wir zu
guter letzt noch mal über
deutschlandweite splitterparteien die
versuche ich ja seit jahren groß
rauszubringen
die großen parteien sind am ende jetzt
gelingt es den radikalen gefährlichen
splitterparteien die wähler in ihre
fänge zu locken und die wollen wir heute
bald vorstellen
ich bin jetzt hier am wahlstand der
partei bibeltreuer christen und ich
stehe jetzt genau neben dem heinz
kaulbach ich bin der landesvorsitzende
bbc jetzt habe ich ihre wahlprogramme
gelesen und es ist ja doch sehr lang
ja wir haben uns überlegt machen wir nur
ganz kurze punkte wären besser gewesen
weil es man braucht lange zum lesen dann
letztendlich was mich auch interessiert
was ich auf der homepage gelesen habe
ist ja der austritt aus der
homosexualität wie genau funktioniert
das meistens oder am besten durch
therapien gut hat die homosexuellen lieb
aber nicht die homosexualität das ist
auch meine meinung
das liegt auch daran weil ich selber
betroffener bin ich finde es auch nicht
okay was kann ich machen sage ich mal
es ist schwierig man kann beten beten
ist eine sache wie ich auch vorher schon
sagt in der therapie war das ist nicht
so ganz einfach aber natürlich die so
unreine gedanken hat man natürlich ist
normal es ganz normal dass wie bei jeder
anderen sagen wer sucht vergleich ist
dass sich guten vergleich das ist
ungefähr gleich so man muss daran
arbeiten und wir können hilfe geben das
machen wir gerne hilfe gebe ich dir
gerade bei der büso und neben mir steht
katarzyna kruczkowski kurz kascha sie
wollen die d-mark zurück ihr motto ist
also nrw raus aus der euro-zone ja nicht
nur in der weg ganz deutschland sollte
wieder souverän werden was
wirtschaftsfragen angeht also ganz
deutschland ein zitat aus der euro-zone
genau was sagen sie denn hardlinern die
sagen wir wollen nicht zurück zur d-mark
sondern zu reichsmark
also das finde ich verrückt also weil
ich allein in nrw bis 50 milliarden euro
und dass wir genau sie brauchen fordert
50 milliarden euro wollen aber die d
mark zurück wäre es dann nicht
sinnvoller zu sagen wir brauchen 100
milliarden mal sicherlich sicherlich der
homosexuelle akt ist natürlich nicht
okay ist klar
schon im alten testament wir schmusen
also jetzt die so eine vorstufe wie auch
schon als nicht normal ansehen wenn es
ohne zunge ist kommt so an ich denke in
den er in den arabischen ländern 7000
bisschen anders wird es vielleicht zu
einer normalen vor was ist ihnen noch
wichtig für die wahl für die wahl ist
wichtig dass möglichst keine extreme
kräfte in den landtag kommen
das war doch schon sehr viel
versprechende parteien es gibt aber auch
kleine parteien die überhaupt gar keine
chance haben über die fünf prozent zu
kommen wie diese partei fdp
traumtänzer und damit zurück ins studio
wir haben schon echt viel erlebt in den
letzten jahren brach
denn das doch alles an einem ort
versammelt werden also zum abrufen all
unsere reporter stücke du meinst so was
wie ein youtube kanal die man jetzt
abonnieren sollte ja wo das beste aus
über zehn jahren heute schon zu sehen
ist und immer neue videos das ist ja
völlig verrückt das ist ja irre das
gucke ich mir jetzt alles an lutz mein
handy